and i blew my quarterback
he was a cheerleader but still
i wasn't on the team
give me a you
[Music]
hi i'm kevin i'm foley we're back today
and we're not from are you garbage
don't listen to that would you rather
fart only once a year but it's the worst
smell
or smell for two weeks
or fart like you do know you shouldn't
be reading
what the [ __ ] what is that an s.a.t
question
today junior jesus christ
would you would you rather fart only
once a year but it's the worst smell in
the world as you smell and you smell for
two weeks or fart like you do now and it
doesn't smell but the color gas comes
out of your ass
or you drop this one bomb and for two
weeks you smell like well that's touring
because when i'm alone i'll be honest
with you i enjoy it
your own your own flavor is not too
shabby is it the worst smell to you the
to the to the world well this is what i
would do i would just go to like an
island for two weeks
fart and just relax because i don't mind
it that much there's no way you got
island for two weeks money
you got to be at work the next day
i would take the color because as a fat
guy whenever somebody farts at a party
everybody thinks it's him and that's
dude i'm telling you growing up it's a
tough look yeah you feel so small
but it's like eggy and everyone's like
yeah he [ __ ] but then what would you
do to prove like oh i don't have green
behind me there you go that's what i'm
saying everybody would know and it
wouldn't smell god no i would make sure
everybody saw me
what kind of life are you leaving at any
time it smells like farts they assume
it's you
it's like i'm getting pulled over like
you see my hands
i would take the worst smell for two
weeks that's crazy
that means you really like your smell
i just want to sit down i cheese cut
myself from time to time
i'd
what are you talking about get out of
here no i i smell ninety seven percent
of my farts bro i i i'll i'll relish it
i like it but i'm not going out of my
way am i [ __ ] ripping a club oh well
then we are no longer friends
are you scratching sniff
uh no i like i we've talked about this
that's just what the butthole the bar is
the ball oh yeah everything now i know
what that smells like i know every odor
that comes out of my actual [ __ ] or
my balls but the farts are different
that comes out of your [ __ ] yeah but
i know what my [ __ ] smells like this
is coming from inside see i feel like
when i when it's particularly
uncomfortable or whatever then i gotta
be like how bad is this you know oh yeah
of course you want to see what the deal
is you're doing scientific research
this is for my files
yeah would you rather have the ability
to see through cards when gambling or
get 150 million what are you nuts not
spending the weekends in the casino yeah
150 million why work for what that's not
really working for if you can just see
it and say hit stay hit stay they'll
catch you with that [ __ ] yeah don't get
hurt you're gonna get black you're not
gonna get 150 mills worth out of [ __ ]
and also you're gonna have the operating
capital store i mean what am i gonna
take my 1500 bucks and turn that to 150
million
no way
to like uno and stuff like that
[ __ ]
would you rather
never have any buffalo sauce food ever
again or only be able to masturbate to
pregnant porn yikes yeah that's a good
one
that's like somebody from the cia wrote
that oh man
this is all like this is on a job
application at google and you got to
pick the right [ __ ] one
i'd lose the buffalos i love buffalo
sauce but be pregnant porn just creeps
me out i feel bad for those expecting
mothers
i i respect poor women
what do we know anything it's working
mom dude
if you have the ability to spray like a
skunk what type of smell would you want
it to be
something yankee candle i would have
said yeah
vanilla swirls apples and cinnamon yeah
something holiday oh just walk in and
[ __ ] set the vibe do you get invited
to every party right away [ __ ] yeah oh
this is a tough one would you rather
wear cargo shorts every day or no socks
ever again
cargo shorts hands down
hands down cargo shorts i could do to no
socks but i also like a good cargo
i wish they panned down and you were
wearing no socks and cargo shorts i'm
wearing cargo pants oh yeah
back in style they're awesome he's not
wearing them because they're in stock
let's be real here i'm wearing them
because you didn't pick them up off
tick-tock
the pockets you just like to look now i
got stuff in there it's nice because it
doesn't weigh down the front pockets
yeah you can't put the phone in there
though you'll feel like kramer with the
pennies
[Laughter]
i've recently started wearing a fanny
pack really yeah not for style pure
pure [ __ ] functionality like out
without it's not under a sweatshirt or
anything it's slim and like i typically
put it behind me
what yeah but that's wilder than just
wearing it out he only wears it
dude he only wears it at jake paul
fights
when
if both your arms were gone
and you could have two kitchen utensils
as arms
what would they be fork and a knife what
am i [ __ ] spatula and a fork spatula
is pretty good in fact you can cut with
the spatula you can flip you can it's
like a big hand just smack your girl's
hands so this bag's pretty [ __ ] good
come on what are we doing
the one with the little slits in there
to get some [ __ ] wind resistance
cooking [ __ ] kitchenaid
ryan imagine trying to go down on a girl
with a fork
i'd want a big spoon for my cereal
and i'm i'm gonna open the door
i'm slowly switching over to eating most
things with a spoon especially at my
house i would just use a spoon so i can
get sauce with the with the meat you
have to cut anything no you just cut it
with the side of the spoon
usually the side of the spoon does the
job i don't know where you're buying
your meat yeah
you're eating it
i'm not eating steak
[Laughter]
anyway i want a spoon hand
i want to spoon here take that kfc
would you rather have everything in your
life showers weather food drinks be hot
or cold i want to say this with 45 years
of of heavy fat guy tendencies
if i could only satisfy food or uh
hunger or thirst it would be thirst and
to satisfy my thirst it's got to be cold
it's gotta be cool i'll take the cold
showers but if i can't have a [ __ ]
cold snapple or a cold soda or a cold
beer what the [ __ ] drinking hot tea
after like a basketball game
you'll never get used to a cold shower
though ever they say that's good for you
now a lot of guys are doing it rogan's
doing it yeah you know joe rogan okay
there's a polar plunge every morning
yeah there you go yeah tony robbins he's
like you can see him being like
yeah that's not good i mean those things
are almost putting him on his ass yeah
but it's worth a cold capri sun i can
tell you that
would you rather get paid one million
dollars a year but have to work
ridiculous hours get a hundred thousand
a year a year to do nothing
i'm working now and i have that now yeah
would you [ __ ] kelly ripa if it had to
be
a threesome with regis filament
since died 100 first of all that's like
my one of my biggest celebrity crushes
is kelly ripa i saw in the upper east
side one time tight body on her still
and i [ __ ] love regis regis
[ __ ] like is
cause let me tell you something this
guy's bonkers
that would be a real nice night if we
did the whole thing we went to like mr
chow's yeah took a look he picks up the
bill oh yeah i dude it almost makes it
better right
i don't have to have sex with him he's
just also involved in the threesome
right i think he smells i mean he smells
real good probably kept it tight all the
way up until it until he passed yeah
like silk underwear and [ __ ] we go back
to his place too oh he's a gentleman you
know he's getting your car in the
morning
for sure get in the car you're getting
breakfast i'm all in with regis yeah
probably a swag bag too
and an nda
a gag order who would win in a fight in
their prime michael keaton or john bon
jovi jon bon jovi's a [ __ ] i don't i
think keaton in his prime yeah for sure
batman what do you do listen here's the
thing you got to pick up some of that
stuff like you know i wouldn't [ __ ] with
i wouldn't [ __ ] with keanu reeves he's
had some automatic weapons straight well
one of the guys you got to pick up a
little bit dude
can you beat up tom cruise because he's
like 5'4 no a lot of people not a shot
in hell a lot of people like yeah he's
five four not a shot
can [ __ ] he would rip you apart you
think you could beat up tom bruce
you're i'm i would say i don't think tom
cruise could beat me up i would say that
he would i don't think tom cruise would
[ __ ] me up i think he would kill you
you're not talking about cold trickle
here dude
you're not i legit think he would break
your neck in under under 30 seconds 100
what are we doing you're crazy he
wouldn't [ __ ] me up i'm not saying you
couldn't beat goose he's never been in a
fight in his life tom cruise top crew
has been in the million fights
not yet choreographed listen i took this
stance for comedic purposes you guys are
putting a lot of holes in my theory well
it's funny because he's in the next room
right now
dude for the views alone i would fight
tom cruise
if your girl had to wear
a mascot head during sex for the rest of
your life
which one would you choose not even a
[ __ ] question philly fanatic
he got that tongue on her
tongue when he does that thing with his
stomach
yeah yeah yeah attic all day fanatic or
swoop from the eagles wouldn't be bad
yeah
chilly san diego chicken i wouldn't kick
out of bed
would you rather
relive your best sports moment or your
best sex moment i don't have either so
[Laughter]
how about losing to the purple team and
coming too fast
what do you want
boys let me take you back to the fall of
all right we were playing lansdale
catholic they were supposed to destroy
us we were up by a touchdown they were
driving into the end zone and the
[ __ ] kid threw a pick six our our d
back got it ran down the field it's the
greatest night of my life
he was a cheerleader but still
i wasn't on the team right here
give me a you
i would love one day we got to get like
a real [ __ ] bona fide superstar
athlete in area yeah yeah because
they've had some sex yeah they have oh
yeah
they're asking two fat guys from billy
would you rather have your balls
permanently stuck to your leg or
permanent swamp ass
i thought i would i would love that if
so if they sold something where i can
stick them to my leg
i need a [ __ ] pocket down there yeah
i need a fanny pack for them
just get out it's brutal i would take to
the leg swamp asses
too much
i don't mind it in fact the way i'm
doing it right now like today whatever's
happening today might be a boxing
situation i don't know but they keep
sticking and i kind of keep it like this
it's like oh that's a great feeling the
peel wall
is a good sensation so it's like it's a
little bit it's a little bonus every now
and then just a little bit of housing
i could use a tuck one of those beverly
hills doctors
for three thousand bucks would you get
your face photoshopped into a gay porn
yeah absolutely why not
and everybody sees it all your boys 20
21 baby that's rock and roll yeah no i
would still go now i wouldn't even do it
for straight porn let alone yeah i'd pay
three grand for one of yours
you know that's funny yeah that's a hard
no we tell the prices with stuff a lot
and we're always like we gotta we gotta
pump it up gonna pump it up for three
grand everyone so i was like yeah
yeah that one is three grand three
stacks was a nice week
we've asked multi-millionaires that
questions like yeah probably three grand
out in the boroughs on a weekend it's a
nice time i'd have to see the guys hog
first i'd have to sign off on his unit
oh yeah can i have a nice piece
yeah yeah yeah yeah what about you're
the one getting [ __ ] all right and you
got no piece you got like a no piece
i got that
now and not three grand
okay
jesus christ
yeah i'm not killing it
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon